gardez la france au fond des yeux ni
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter à votre place je la ramène à un
peu moins mais si vous ne réussissez pas
c'est qu'il vous manque qu'une seule
chose un tout petit détail le front fais
les valises à paris de ce qui lui arrive
à la baisse
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine c'est l'inattendu et vous
êtes les bienvenus après notre petite
escapade sétoise open brassens nous
sommes de retour ici aline armes avec
géraldine corner labo et camille
d'auxerre journaliste à la rédaction
dina bonjour à toutes les deux alors
qu'amy c'est la coop 26 organisé à
glasgow qui a retenu votre attention
cette semaine oui énième grand rendez
vous international sur le climat un
rassemblement dénoncé par la jeunesse et
par la célèbre militante greta tanberg
comme étant un échec du blabla entre les
dirigeants du monde est déjà à la
première coop à berlin en 95 en
allemagne on envisager ce rassemblement
comme étant surtout un symbole sans trop
rien n'en attend les militants
écologistes n'étaient pas non plus très
nombreux
quelques pauvres banderoles pour prendre
à témoin les délégués à la conférence
des nations unies sur le climat mais les
délégués sont passés loin des banderoles
par les portiques de sécurité il y à
d'autres menaces que le réchauffement de
la terre le centre des congrès de berlin
va donc se transformer pendant une
dizaine de jours en une sorte de tour de
babel de l'environnement mais le plus
vraisemblable c'est qu'à l'échelle du
monde aucune décision concrète n'est à
attendre de ce sommet de berlin les
véritables décisions seront prises lors
d'un prochain sommet en 1997 voilà 26
ans après c'est vrai que ça n'a pas
beaucoup bougé alors vous géraldine vous
allez nous parler cinéma avec le nouveau
film de jacques audiard les olympiades
actuellement en salles rien à voir avec
paris 2024 n'ont rien à voir les
olympiades c'est un quartier dans le
xiiie arrondissement et donc le film
porte le nom de ce quartier c'est un
ensemble de tours que jacques audiard
film sous toutes les coutures ou quatre
jeunes adultes s'aiment se perdent
flotte enfin bref avec ce décor en béton
on oublierait presque que c'est à paris
on est bien loin des immeubles
haussmanniens c'est tour nous
transportent parfois même à tokyo en
1978 ça me fait penser à cette archive
une émission d'une heure était consacrée
à ce nouveau quartier tout neuf les
olympiades les derniers tours derniers
retours étaient sortis de terre juste
deux ans auparavant et ont demandé aux
habitants de ce tour ce qu'ils pensaient
de leur quartier et voici comment les
jeunes parler des olympiades jeu phoques
les trois tours d'athènes mexico et
sapporo au niveau de l'esthétique elles
sont jolies mais c'est pas habite a 100
mètre de beaux boubous n'est pas habile
on avance on a trop pressé parmi les
tours y en a pleins partout et tout
autour absente dans des cages
partout en garde les auteurs croissance
et de se mettre aux trucs à resserrer le
vieux paris c'était mieux avec des
petits îlots depuis six ans mon
impression dans le béton dans le béton
c'est pourri moi je me plais ici parce
qu'il ya mes copains il y aura pour mes
copains c'est mort
on a chacun dans la tour quand j'ai fait
ça comme ça on cherche pas à connaître
voilà on aurait envie de les retrouver
en c2
exactement et on aura envie de les
retrouver surtout la jeune zouloue qui
était apprenti comptable et qui dit que
le béton c'est pourri ainsi elle se
reconnaît un appel est lancé elle a bien
sûr les réseaux sociaux et on s'occupera
des lits six années nature du voilà ça
c'est pour l'actualité de la semaine
alors que s'est il passé à cette même
période de l'année par le passé pour le
savoir il faut regarder le zapping de
linate ange
bonjour
la première attaque a eu lieu dans la
salle de spectacle du bataclan une
fusillade a éclaté une prise d'otage est
en cours les hommes du raid sont en
action deuxième attaque aux portes du
stade de france à saint-denis un
kamikaze aurait fait sauter sa ceinture
d'explosifs
la troisième attaque s'est déroulée dans
un restaurant du 10e arrondissement près
de la république rien n'avait laissé
prévoir qu'il était ce jour-là
particulièrement souffrent en effet
comme chaque jour il s'était installé
vers 19 heures devant son poste de
télévision
[Musique]
longtemps
attention avant
car la boue
ce néant
si tu n'en
[Musique]
qu'en vertu de la nouvelle constitution
japonaise l'empereur n'est plus un dieu
vivant mais le symbole du japon le mythe
est disparu le rite lui n'a pas changé
dans son état natal était à feu et à
sang en 1976 celle que les noirs
d'afrique du sud appelait
respectueusement mama africa vivaient
déjà en exil depuis 15 ans elle luttait
contre l'apartheid et ne pouvait donc le
faire que de l'étranger
à tapas tu as un petit rien en zoulou a
fait le tour du monde bonsoir
[Musique]
c'est l'une des révolutions qui a marqué
l'histoire de notre paysage audiovisuel
camille il ya 40 ans les radios qu'on
appelait alors les radios pirates
obtenaient le droit d'émettre en france
oui avec la loi du 9 novembre
1981 la bande fm et libéré imaginez vous
à l'époque on allume et sa radio et on
découvre et plein de nouvelles stations
de nouvelles radio ça paraît un peu
banal aujourd'hui mais pas à l'époque
car ces radios jusque là n'avait pas le
droit d'émettre librement les fréquences
étaient soumises au monopole d'état ça
veut dire en d'autres termes que seul
l'état avait le droit d'émettre des
radios mais avant cela avant cette loi
dans les années 70 sur tout et bien des
petits malins ont diffusé leur propre
radio tout coller des émetteurs dans
leur appartement dans le virage dans
leur garage même voilà me parler en
connaissance de cause nathanel
dans les années 70 j'écoutais
tranquillement la radio de bons de votre
papa et de ses petits malins dont qui se
battait pour la liberté d'expression en
france
voici en train d'émettre clandestinement
l'une de ces radios partis à l'assaut
d'un bastion célèbre le monopole des
radios pirates hallassou du monopole
d'état de l'autre côté de votre
transistors à modulation de fréquence
vous écoutez génération en 2000 sur 96
mégahertz et en stéréo dans les années
70 aucune radio privée ne peut émettre
depuis le territoire français c'est la
loi alors des radios pirates libre se
multiplient sur tout le territoire une
radio libre est avant tout locales
indépendantes de pouvoir financier ou
politique des radios locales musicale
contestataires sont installés
clandestinement mais ça ne plaît pas à
tout le monde comme le réalisateur jean
christophe averty figure de la
télévision et de la radio française ces
palabres une région quartier sainte
euphémie fillette regard c'est
complètement imbécile c'est là
l'aberration démocratique
force de tout le monde va parler
normalement en parler cette année le lui
en déplaise les pirates des ondes
multiplie les émetteurs sur les toits
des grandes villes et ça paraît assez
simple la solution la plus simple
consiste h et en commerce un émetteur
modulation de fréquence au canon rajoute
un ampli qui vous permet de couvrir tout
paraît en émission sans aucun problème
ainsi naissent radio campus radio ivre
ou radio verte
[Musique]
radio verte est arrivé hier sur paris
elles sont arrivées par provocation pour
rompre les carcans de la non
communication des radios que le pouvoir
politique en place sous valéry giscard
d'estaing combat poursuivi brouille est
interdite parfois même avec force les
manifestants voulaient protester contre
le brouillage des émissions de lorraine
coeur d'acier la radio clandestine de la
cg lorraine coeur d'acier ne sera pas la
seule victime radio riposte on fera les
frais en
1979 c'est la radio pirate du parti
socialiste c'est ici dans ses locaux de
la cité malesherbes que la station
pirate socialiste à diffuser le message
de françois mitterrand tu l'émission est
brouillé la police arrive sur les lieux
pour constater un flagrant délit et
rechercher le matériel qui a servi à
l'émission françois mitterrand le
premier secrétaire du parti est inculpé
pour violation du monopole
le parti socialiste continuera seuls
actions
tant que ne sera pas respecté la liberté
de la presse
dans notre pays
libérés les ondes il en fera même une
promesse de campagne élu président en
1981 à peine installé à l'elysée le
gouvernement socialiste organise la
bande fm je suis en train de présenter
au nom du gouvernement de la gauche un
projet de loi qui vise à ouvrir une
liberté qui jusqu'ici étaient interdites
en faveur des petites stations de radio
privées locales le 9 novembre
1981 la première loi sur les radios
locales privées et promulguée elle fixe
la puissance d'émission le statut des
radios et interdit la publicité un an
après cette loi près de 2000 radio sont
recensés en france et donc plus de 2000
radio sont recensés
au début des années 80 qui a mis combien
en reste-t-il aujourd'hui et bien
aujourd'hui le csa comptabilise 1021 une
radio privée en france donc vous voyez
la plupart de ces radios qui sont nés
après cette loi de 81 n'ont pas survécu
elles n'ont pas survécu notamment avec
l'autorisation de la publicité en 1984
forcément ça a rendu le marché
concurrentiel commerciales et des radios
pirates femmes ont dû mettre les clés
sous la porte comme carbone 14 par
exemple merci beaucoup camille
[Musique]
c'est l'un des onze jours fériés de
notre calendrier le 11 novembre jour de
commémoration de la première guerre
mondiale rendent hommage ou un million
trois cent mille militaires français
morts au combat plus de cent ans après
l'armistice à quoi correspond le devoir
de mémoire quels en sont les symboles
comment ont-ils évolué avec nous pour en
parler frédérick gersal historien et
chroniqueur bonjour frédéric bonjour
matin alors risque eu le 11 novembre
parle encore au français aujourd'hui oui
je pense que oui tout simplement parce
que nous avons tous et toutes un
monument aux morts dans notre village où
notre ville et on passe devant pour
aller à la boulangerie pour aller
chercher son journal ou pour suivre les
émissions de france info alors le 11
novembre jour de commémoration est un
rendez vous devenu très politique et
finalement ça a commencé assez tôt
géraldine puisque c'était peu de temps
après la fin de la première guerre
exactement à sa date de 1920 donc deux
ans après l'armistice et c'est une idée
qui vient à la base du royaume uni le
royaume uni qu'avait décidé de douala de
mettre en place cette idée de soldat
inconnu donc vite la france se dépêche
pour avoir elle aussi son soldat inconnu
en 1920 et comment faire pour le choisir
elle fait alors appel à augustin qui
était un point lui survivants et il
expliquait comment lui-même il a choisi
entre huit cercueils le cercueil qui
deviendra le cercueil du soldat inconnu
il expliquait sa en 1965 à la télévision
elle écoute c'est un verbe 1 le 10
novembre 1920 que fut désigné parmi huit
corps le soldat inconnu le ministre
andré maginot présidait la cérémonie
le jeune soldat qui incombait le soin
c'était augustin monsieur machine ou m'a
remis un bouquet en me disant de
cercueil sur lequel vous déposerez ce
bouquet sera celui qui rend sous l'arc
de triomphe pour immortaliser tous les
morts de la guerre
j'ai déposé mon bouquet sur le sixième
cercueil
j'ai pensé additionner les chiffres de
mon régiment le 132 ici reposera
désormais un soldat français inconnu
depuis 1920 il est le fils de toutes les
mères qui n'ont pas retrouvé leur fils
il est l'époux de toutes celles dont le
foyer a été prématurément brisé
valérie beaucoup de mystère autour de ce
soldat inconnu bien sûr et alors il a
fallu rechercher des corps d'abord et
c'est pour ça qu'on avait demandé aux
généraux qui étaient sur les le terrain
dans les neuf lieux principaux c'est à
dire les la somme l'artois le verdun
évidemment là où il ya eu tant de morts
et on a exhumé des corps on cherchait
surtout à ce qu'ils soient français
évidemment s'agissait pas de mettre
comme ça d'un inconnu un allemand donc
les questions sont posées et sur les
neuf corps n'y a que 8 qui sont arrivées
jusqu'à jusqu'à verdun et c'est là où le
jeune poilu il avait 19 ans à ce poids
luc et qui en parle bien des années plus
tard augustin quand il a choisi qu'il a
posé ce bouquet de deuil est rouge et
blanc qui avait été cueilli à verdun et
qu'il apposait sa devant le ministre de
futur ministre de la guerre qui était
ministre des pensions andré maginot
curieusement ministre des pensions vous
devenez après ministre de la guerre et
c'est là qu'ils aient déclaré la seconde
guerre mondiale il ya une certaine
logique finalement
géraldine en plus de ce symbole national
chaque ville chaque commune va se doter
d'un monument aux morts oui mais juste
avant ça j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur
la tombe là la symbolique de la tombe du
soldat inconnu vous parce que les
monuments commencer c'est partout en
province mais à paris le fait de choisir
l'arc de triomphe les qu'on mette un
soldat inconnu enterré sous cet axe de
triomphe on l'a entendu un petit peu
dans l'archipel tout à l'heure c'est cet
homme en fait qui se substitue à toutes
les tons que les familles ne peuvent pas
avoir c'est un peu ça aussi complètement
et d'ailleurs il y avait une grande
question qui était posée beaucoup
d'anciens combattants il était quand
même très nombreux puisqu'ils avaient
trois millions de blessés vous parliez
d'un million trois cent mille morts il y
avait aussi trois millions de blessés
dans leur chair dans leur corps dans
l'horreur dans leur esprit dans l'or
donc ils avaient un poids énorme on
considère que tous les hommes entre 25
et 50 ans à l'époque 90 % étaient des
anciens combattants dont qu'ils avaient
une pression et il voulait absolument
que ce soldat inconnu fut enterré au
panthéon avec les grands hommes et
maintenant heureusement les grandes
femmes
de notre temps mais voilà la pression
n'était pas suffisante le politique lui
voulait quelque chose sous l'arc de
triomphe ça a mis du temps parce que
1920 avec les images que nous on a vu en
fait le korn est inhumé sous l'arbre de
tnf 121 absolument en janvier 1921 très
exactement et jusque là il était dans
une chapelle ardente dans un des pieds
des quatre pieds que l'on voit ici de de
l'arc de triomphe alors outre l'arc de
triomphe chaque ville géraldine va se
doter d'un monument ben oui et ça c'est
assez énorme hein juste quelques
chiffres entre 1920 et 1925 36000
monuments ont été érigées soit 15 par
jours parfois plusieurs pour une seule
et même ville un phénomène de masse qui
correspond aussi à la mort de masse
c'est un projet qui était financièrement
soutenu par l'état et ça c'est assez
unique régionale alors et par l'état et
puis par vous et moi si je veux dire les
gens qui évidemment pleurer leur leurs
frères leurs pairs lors leur fils et
beaucoup ont contribué justement à
l'élaboration de ces monuments aux morts
qui sont nombreux parce que en fait
quand on était morts pour la france il y
avait une décision de l'état et vous
étiez inscrits sur des listes dans votre
mairie mais il fallait rentrer dans la
dans la mairie et puis voir les listes
pour savoir ce que voulait la les
anciens combattants s'étaient que ça
puisse être lu par tout le monde à tout
moment et qu'on soit en permanence
choqué bringuebalé par cette guerre
terrible qui avait fait tant de morts en
quelques années et souvent ça va de 1914
à 1919 ne l'oublions pas 1919 beaucoup
de poids lui sont morts des suites de
leurs blessures et il figure aussi
certains sur les monuments aux morts
alors viens de voir sur ces images
il ya beaucoup de styles différents pour
ses monuments aux morts des pierres du
bronze du marbre pour les communes les
plus riches des monuments républicain
patriotiques à la gloire des soldats
morts au combat il ya aussi quelques
monument pacifiste ou carrément anti
militariste comment c'est possible eh
ben c'est possible et y en a pas qu'un
seul d'ailleurs c'est ça qui est dingue
il y en a plus d'une centaine où on peut
lire donc guère à la guerre maudite soit
la guerre contre la guerre à la
fraternité des peuples c'est étonnant
hein mais c'est exactement ce qu'on peut
lire sur des monuments aux morts et qui
vous chante i somme toute assez logique
pour des familles feront de lier qu'elle
perdu un enfant ou un parent très mal vu
à l'époque d'être antimilitariste comme
ça et surtout vraiment ils ont été
construites dans les années 20 sap a été
construit après la guerre on est encore
en plein dedans ces monuments étaient
vraiment très très mal vu à l'époque
jamais inauguré par les préfets et ne
voulait pas les inaugurer et même des
années après ces monuments continue de
faire parler comme agence ue dans la
creuse en 1988 ecoutez jean sioux petite
commune de 300 âmes à tout pour célébrer
dignement le 11 novembre
un monument aux morts sur la place du
village un défilé fourni avec autorité
et anciens combattants une gerbe
somptueuse et une minute de silence mais
sur le monument un enfant lève le poing
et maudit la guerre il y avait eu une
instruction près officiel du ministère
de la guerre à l'époque en 1900
24 face à ça remonte tout de suite après
la guerre de 14-18 pour que ce monument
ne soit pas officiellement inauguré on a
toujours été très libre penseur agences
ou pour ne pas dire un peu provocateur y
a qu'à écouter les enfants du village le
11 novembre
les aides et les noms sans papiers jouer
un des monuments aux morts contre la
guerre c'était complètement à
contre-courant on l'a dit certains
préfets de l'époque par les mêmes
d'engagement à la désertion comme on
explique voilà cette centaine c'est
assez rare mais quand même sans monument
aux morts pacifistes comme ça a été dit
là vous avez entendu l'inauguration le
monument est construit dans les années
20 et menez inaugurait que dans les
années 85 donc il a fallu 60 ans pour
que tout cela tout cela changerait alors
effectivement ça fait partie de ces
curiosités mais c'est aussi pas mal de
se dire maudite soit la guerre et puis
on sait que 20 ans plus tard
malheureusement le feu va encore
dérouler ces drames frédéric est ce que
le monument aux morts est un bon outil
pour le devoir de mémoire moi je pense
que oui parce que le 11 novembre on
rassemble les enfants des écoles on
rassemble la population tous ceux qui
veulent venir évidemment sont les
bienvenus un discours est prononcé par
le ou la mer
enfin de l'élu en tout cas un discours
qui a été écrit à paris par le ministère
alors aujourd'hui c'est une ministre qui
est déléguée chargée de la mémoire
d'ailleurs et des anciens combattants
geneviève darrieussecq donc un texte
sera lu dans toutes les communes de
france les 36000 communes de france le
même jour à la même ces monuments aux
morts deviennent reste le lieu de
rassemblement pour les cérémonies du
11-novembre géraldine les années passent
la cérémonie nationale sous l'arc de
triomphe est immuable jusqu'au mandat de
nicolas sarkozy oui on a une cérémonie
qui tous les ans les archives nous le
prouve c'est la même chose c'est neymar
et monique et silencieuse donc on voit
on allume la flamme on pose des gerbes
donc sous le salary de triomphe nicolas
sarkozy va complètement remodelé cette
cérémonie en 2007 avec choses inédites
un discours c'est la première fois qu'un
discours et effet et ce discours c'est
une ode à l'europe donc c'est très
intéressant aussi de l'étudier 2008 il
fait la cérémonie on voit sur les images
à verdun non plus aux champs-elysées et
ça c'est assez unique alors que le
dernier poilu lazare ponticelli est
décédé il invite en gueule à merkel sous
l'arc de triomphe on écoute un extrait
de ce reportage c'est une première c'est
la première fois qu'un chef du
gouvernement allemand participe à la
commémoration de l'armistice de 1918
l'hymne allemand hammam retenti à
l'issue de la cérémonie pour l'histoire
au nom de la paix au nom surtout de
l'amitié franco allemande
des instants solennels audacieux parfois
la marseillaise
et en réponse deutschland lead première
fois que l'hymne allemand et jouer ici
dans ce lieu de souvenir
ensuite la chancelière allemande et le
président de la république ranime rond
la flamme du soldat inconnu quand
expliqué cédric gersal qu'il a fallu
attendre 2009 pour que un chancelier
allemand soit présent à la cérémonie du
11 novembre aux champs-elysées moi je me
souviens aussi de ce qu'a fait françois
mitterrand en donnant la main à helmut
kohl on se souvient tous étaient pas été
pas choisi ce n'était pas aux champs
elysées s'était pas sous l'arc de
triomphe ni devant le soldat inconnu
c'était à
adour monde devant l'ossuaire évidemment
ça deux symboles complètement différent
alors pourquoi il a fallu attendre si
longtemps je pourrais pas répondre
vraiment directement à la je dirai juste
un mot sur la flamme faut faire
attention parce qu on a rallumé la
flamme tous les soirs à 18h30 on l'a
ravive tout simplement parce qu'on
tourne un petit robinet de gaz qui fait
que la flamme qui est déjà présente mais
cacher un peu sous le choc d'un seul
coup voilà sort de sort du sol si je
puis dire au dessus du soldat inconnu
est ce que la france a le même rapport
avec ses monuments aux morts selon lui
on est à paris à bordeaux à marseille
est ce qu'il ya des régions où le
houleux l'hommage où le souvenir est
davantage présent je pense qu en
alsace-moselle par exemple c'est sans
doute différent d'une grande partie de
la du reste de la france on sait le
séparatisme le rattachement à la france
après et n'oublions pas qu'il y avait
des des monuments aux morts de en 1871
c'est à dire que ça existait déjà la
presse est en guerre contre la prusse
mais c'était une guerre perdue or là
c'est une guerre gagnée et c'est aussi
cette symbolique qu'on veut montrer
évidemment au monde et dans son village
en disant voilà on s'est pas battu pour
rien et tous ces morts tous ses parents
tous ses amis ses voisins ses collègues
ses confrères eh bien ils sont pas morts
pour rien winx n'ont pas été blessés
pour rien en tout cas cette journée
d'hommage à évoluer
sous nicolas sarkozy puisque le 11
novembre est devenu une journée de
commémoration pour tous les soldats
morts pour la france est-ce que c'est
comme ça que le devoir de mémoire doit
évoluer je pense oui et d'ailleurs on le
voit sur les inscriptions des monuments
aux morts puisque le ministère n'est
plus dédié seulement aux anciens
combattants de la guerre de 14 ou de la
guerre de 39 mais aussi aux anciens
combattants actuel ou aux morts pour
pour la france sur les terrains
étrangers actuellement encore ça que
cette image était assez dingue dès 2011
et c'est des enfants donc leur père est
mort en afghanistan qui signait le
registre du soldat inconnu ça c'était
c'était une première que tonio et des
enfants qui signe sa montre que la
présence des enfants est toujours et
toujours là autour des monuments moment
au moins d'heures jeu j'habite un petit
village mais je vous assure que les
enfants des écoles viennent avec leur
leur maîtresse le remettre leurs
instituteurs pour participer pour
écouter pour écouter l'hymne national et
chanter autour du monument aux morts
géraldine vous vous teniez à diffuser
une archive pour terminer cette émission
oui exactement c'est une archive qui
date de 2003 c'est lazare ponticelli
j'en ai déjà un peu parlé c'est le
dernier poilu il est mort cinq ans plus
tard il était interviewé donc en 2003 il
parlait justement de la mémoire du
devoir de mémoire lui disait que on
allait forcément un jour ou l'autre
oublier cette grande guerre mais il
parlait aussi en 2003 de l'absurdité de
cette guerre on l'écoutait
pas feindre la guerre on lui a fait
faire sans savoir pourquoi
c'est sam toute vision c'est comme dom
en coton fera une guerre les uns que la
voix une seule fois pourquoi
on est en 2003 on et 85 ans après la
guerre il n'a toujours pas compris pour
qu'elle ait la guerre c'est assez dingue
quand même c'est ça résume bien ce qu'on
appelle la grande guerre la boucherie ou
que c'est complètement absurde en fait
et où on partait vous savez avec la
fleur au fusil on vient avec les
moustaches de l'empereur dans quelques
temps quelques jours quelques heures
voilà on sait ce qu'il en est devenu
merci beaucoup prési réinstalle merci
de nous avoir accompagnés dans j'étais
ravi dans cette inattendue consacré au
11 novembre et merci à vous géraldine
alors on va se quitter avec je sais que
vous connaissez notre traditionnel
pépites à l'inattendu lors cette semaine
retour de vacances des écoliers alors
pourquoi ils sont encore fatigué en
cadets en 1958 les actualités françaises
avait la solution la sieste comme
discipline pédagogique avec vous allez
voir un système tellement ingénieux
qu'on a envie de le développer dans les
bureaux de l'ina
chez les jeunes élèves les classes
d'après-midi somnolente ou dissiper se
sont toujours révélées moins productrice
que celle du matin à l'école primaire
devant une expérience est en cours à
l'instigation du docteur max fourestier
la sieste a été promu au rang de
discipline pédagogique grâce à un
ingénieux système de lits collective
pliant la classe b la rentrée se
transforme en dortoir quelques minutes
suffisent
chaque après midi depuis un an trempez
fillettes de 5 à 8 ans consacrent
l'heure qui suit le déjeuner au sommeil
les rideaux sont tirés pour la pénombre
et une musique douce est dispensée par
un électrophone
et 7 heures perdues est en réalité une
heure gagne après la sieste les élèves
sont charge décontractée la santé des
enfants est amélioré par ce régime qui
rétablit l'équilibré perturbé par les
conditions de la vie moderne
ça donne envie quand même moi ce n'était
pas comme ça l'assiette réinstaller sa
au bureau je sais pas de tirer quand
même des grands dortoirs week bonne idée
et sous les médecins nous le dise
infecté un quart d'heure de sieste tous
les après-midi ce n'est pas une heure
car du seigneur gagner moi je retiens ça
merci à tous les deux en tout cas on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine sur le
canal 27 et et toute la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux que ce soit ce dina ou
de france info émission préparée avec
les documentalistes florence tu sais que
la brûler et aimer en gala merci à elle
et merci à vous d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]